today we feature Donna Strickland a
world-renowned optical physicist widely
recognized for her groundbreaking
contributions to the field of pulse
lasers in 2018 she was honored with the
Nobel Prize in physics for the Practical
implementation of chirped pulse
amplification alongside her colleague
Gerard Maru her brilliantly blazing
research has left the lasting Mark in
many fields and most notably is
significantly Advanced laser eye surgery
something I benefited from myself many
many years ago which is enabled doctors
to help millions of people around the
world Donna fell in love with science
early on and as she grew up so did her
love of science today she'll share some
of that love with us so buckle up and
get ready to peek into the fascinating
Mind of a Nobel laurat welcome everybody
to this episode of the into the
impossible podcast today is a special
segment uh part of our series called
fake like a Nobel Prize winner and
that's because we have an actual honest
to goodness Nobel Prize winner the
fourth one has been in this room and the
17th one that's been on the podcast so
I'm just Overjoyed with gratitude that
Donna is here we're going to talk about
technology we're going to nerd out as
experimental physicist but the first
thing I really want to talk about is
pedagogy and sort of philosophically um
how do you approach dealing with
students have have you seen changes in
your attitude or perspective in teaching
over the years have there been any
technological improvements I'm always
looking to learn different tools to
apply for my students and curious about
how you approach and divide your time
research and pedagogy so what is your
philosophy as as an educator as a mentor
a student well now I don't teach because
I won the Nobel Prize and I'm traveling
all the time before that the only thing
I mean I did follow physics education
research and the one thing I am doing
for undergrad um education right now is
changing the the labs I am supposedly
the director of undergrad Labs but since
I won they've hired someone to do the
actual work but it's still my vision and
really because of waterl we uh we have
this perimeter in soup theoretical
physics so so many of our students come
thinking the only kind of really cool
physics is Theory so I'm trying to fight
back on that and say no I think I seeing
things happen in front of your eyes and
Optical physics is the best for that one
of the things I'm aiming for is to have
a first year jiz lab just for the honor
physics students because I want the
students from the that program to leave
that lab coin too bad for the rest of
you you don't get to see these laps cuz
usually first year undergrad laps leave
everybody like oh I'd rather be a
theorist right and so it's not going to
be to teach them Concepts because
physics education research has shown
that the first year Labs where we've
done them for decades doesn't do that so
instead we'll still have a set of first
year LS to teach them skills and stuff
but this one and the one I wanted to do
was white light generation that requires
two expensive of a laser and possibly
one where laser safety may be more of a
concern so so we're just going to do in
my Optics home we're going to do
frequency doubling and let the students
just say well just think about the
experiment yourself you want to find out
is it energy dependent power dependent
intensity dependent and a little pre
thing about what those differences are
but just let them figure out how to do
the experiment and let them make
observations and of course they probably
won't come up with the right answer and
who cares nobody cares it's the fact
that they get to see it they get to
think like an experimentalist go what
would should I try here with with the
equipment that I have with the you know
schemes we have what can I try to figure
out if it's power dependent and
dependent or intensity dependent and
just see the light just turning from
infrared to Blue is one thing you know
that's just it's a cool thing to see so
that's what I'm trying to do is just get
them excited about what is science
because I think the biggest mistake we
make teaching all the way up through
undergrad is we're always teaching what
science we already know and science is
about not knowing right it's really
about know figuring out how to ask the
question why or how properly it's not
about learning how everything else has
already been done not saying we don't
need to know that but we don't really
instruct asking you know the right
questions as opposed to knowing the
answers yeah and often times I feel like
students get these canned experiments
and we already know that they're going
to work and they and they don't work and
that's frustrating and yes but that's
when you learn right when you this thing
is supposed to actually do and that's
why you know I always find it so much
fun when my theoretical colleagues come
into the lab and they're stumbling about
like their you know you know toddlers in
an NBA game trying to play against
LeBron James or Toronto Raptors in your
case uh closer to you but um what when
you think about the kind of crown jewels
we were talking earlier before we
started recording about you know the
paradigmatic Nobel Prize winners the
Einstein the fermes these are well fery
has experimental capability as well but
but the directs and the you know Gman
and F and it's almost seem that that the
prestige in physics goes a lot to the
theorist and and yet I find that a
complete physicist Should Know My
Philosophy is my grad students need to
know as much Theory as an as a theorist
grad student but they don't have to do
new theories what about like when you
were teaching when you advising what is
the experimental minimum or what what do
you wish theoretically inclined students
like those at Perimeter who are some of
the best that they knew about experiment
what should they know about experimental
physics the
limits mostly uh it's the limitation uh
but also I think most people don't
realize that how much patience and
experimentalist needs and the fact that
the theorist gets to non-stop always
think about their Theory at the end of
the day it doesn't stop they pick it up
exactly where they left it the next day
and might have to remind themselves a
little bit whereas we turn our lasers
off we spend the majority of the time
just getting the laser back the where it
was the day before before we can even
start our experiment right and so
there's a lot of that frustration that
goes on but also I think that we
actually get to see physics happening in
front of our eyes and and I to me that's
uh the most exciting part of it is that
we just get to see things happening when
um when I think back and I have a
lowered uh Spirits maybe I think about
uh Galileo and he was such a just an
amazing writer as well as a scientist
obviously and he would say things like
uh measure what is measurable and make
measurable what is not yet so and I
wonder when you were you know devising
this new you know here to for unknown
technique was it done you know with a
theological purpose in mind that you
wanted to solve a specific problem that
would lead to know lace in and all sorts
of other things or the technological
breakthroughs that youve that you've
enabled or your technology is enabled or
was it just you know playing around like
what what was it was it driven from a
fundamental or with an ultimate goal of
a technological application there was an
actual goal to do a fundamental physics
exploration we were trying to do a high
order uh nonlinear Optical uh experiment
whereas with regular lasers they were
able to simultaneously absorb the energy
of two or three photons we were going to
jump try to jump to nine photons and so
that was doct going to required just a
regular laser it had to be an intense
laser in order to have that Photon
density and so we had the actual
practical goal of needing the intense
laser but it was to just study how does
light and matter interact when the
intensity gets that high that was you
know so so we were not thinking how to
cut glass we were not thinking how this
could be used for medicine there was
none of that at all it was it was a
fundamental pursuit of Optics but we
needed the tool to do it so you had to
invent the measurement tool to do
something that yeah I would say when I
have on you know someone uh U of of very
high caliber and I'm blessed to have on
many guests of of just great great um
accomplishment but I always say you know
um I have to ask you about the actual
Nobel Prize I have to ask you it would
be like if I had Rush here the rock band
Rush and I didn't ask them to play you
know Limelight it's just it's not a good
skill for a podcaster to have to neglect
a description from the creator of this
so can you explain what is a chirp what
what does this have to what was the
actual breakthrough discovery that ended
up being the object of recognition that
resulted in your Nobel Prize so first
the word chirp we could have just called
it stretched pulse amplification cuz
that's really what it is but a bird's
chirp is the fact that it's audio
frequency changes in time uh which is
you know the sound you make right
they're those the notes they play and it
turns out that to stretch our pulse we
use dispersion and we use it in a fiber
that's just that the red colors trampel
faster than the blue colors so although
they all start together by the end the
red is out ahead of the blue unless a
chirp so we called it chirp pul ocation
and the point is that like I said we
were already in the range where you
could have a second order or third order
nonlinearity just with lasers and and
this is what was stopping people from
pushing the laser uh Power even higher
when you tried to amplify a short pulse
it got too powerful and the nonlinear
interactions actually cause damage in
the rots okay and I like to say that for
the experiment what we were trying to
build was a laser Hammer because
sometimes it's energy which is the total
number of photons because each Photon
carries some energy laser Fusion which
has just worked a year or so ago finally
uh at least got scientific Break Even is
an energy in gives an energy out but
like pushing the nail into a piece of
wood you can push a you might it doesn't
go in but you wrap it in and then it
goes so this so non the neuroptics is
like that it's the photon density not
the total number of photons so so when
you put the short pulse in and got it
Amplified it was just the density of
photons so high nonlinear Optics
happened and it caused damage to the rod
and so we couldn't do that and so then
we had to work around that and it's a a
very simple uh workaround you take your
short pulse you make it very long bring
the photon density then what the
amplification does is just multiplies
how many photons there are and gives
total number of photons but they're
still stretched far apart and then when
you're safely out of the amplifier you
can press them all back together so you
have your Photon density high for the
experiment of the application but you've
not damaged your amplify I see okay does
the polarization state of the photons
play any role whatsoever in it or can it
be
unpolarized or dichroic or barrent F you
can do it all of those ways um one of
the few problems that we had when we're
first developing it is we were the first
people a short pulse necessarily has all
the colors right because one a single
color has to go on forever and then you
start adding those colors they cancel
each other and that's how you make a
short pulse so we were really one of the
first to then even try to amplify a
Broadband color into these amplifiers
and we ended up finding out this
oscillation through our colors and
that's because because we were using
polarization switches to switch the
pulse in and out of the amplifier and
there's a thin plate and that thin
Plate's an etalon and that was causing
the problem so we had to work around
that we had to get the plate out of
there or we couldn't have made it work
hey there fellow Cosmic adventurers it's
me your Fearless guide through the
wonders of the universe Professor Brian
key as a passionate educator and science
Communicator my mission is to make
learning captivating and fun you see
equipping students with the tools they
need to unlock the mysteries of the
univers is not just about wrot
memorization it's about turning the
entire process into an adventure one
they won't want to quit and by making it
into a thrilling Journey it'll be one
filled with excitement and a touch of
playfulness and that's why I love
brilliant so much brilliant is an
intuitive and Hands-On platform that
encourages you to approach stem subjects
like science technology engineering and
math the way a scientists like me does
with brilliant you don't just learn new
things you learn how to think and that
in my home humble opinion is the key to
education it's really the best way to
learn brilliant offers a wide variety of
lessons in different stem Fields like
mathematics and computer science their
courses range from basic to Advanced
levels and they arm you with new content
from cuttingedge disciplines like
cryptography and computer science and
you get that information every single
month increasing your learning
adventures and taking a journey that's
uniquely tailored to you you can even
unlock Cosmic wonders from Stellar life
cycles to the fate of their Universe in
their astrophysics course approved by
Yours Truly to try everything brilliant
has to offer for free for a full 30 days
visit brilliant.org
drr Brian keing Dr Brian keing or click
on the link in the description below the
first 200 of you will get 20% off
brilliant's annual premium subscription
now back to the episode so we we can we
can get back to some of the technical
details and nerd out maybe in a little
bit um in the remaining minutes of that
we have but I want to talk about lasers
so lasers reportedly have been as a
category have garnered the largest sheer
of Nobel Prize oh that's good to know I
don't know that as they should they just
did again that's right so first of all I
wanted to get a comment on that and then
second of all uh comment on um you were
at Florence Berkeley National lver or
Florence Florence liore National LL yeah
up north here in the sunny California
and I want to get uh some some thoughts
on some of the projects that uh folks
like Charlie towns were working on
including communicating with aliens or
looking for signals from short pulses of
laser energy first could you please
comment on this most recent Nobel Prize
won by three physicists of course uh
just a few weeks ago that was agustini
KRA and
luier so what what how did you react to
that I always said you said it was a
good choice obviously I was very happy
about it um I actually worked uh did my
post talk with Paul cork of not so we
kind of did think he might win if out of
seconds one but I mean I don't want to
take it away from the other three cuz
they all deserve the Nobel Prize too and
so obviously we're happy when I am an
ultra laser person and that that's the
ultimate Ultra frust right now is out of
seconds also most out ofc work is done
with CPA lasers and so it was our laser
that helped uh push it helped push it
but it's funny when I say that what I
was trying to do for my PhD is night3
harmonics and Y saw the 33rd harmonic
before I even got to it and blew my
thesis right know so she actually saw
higher harmonics without CPA uh but now
it's it's yes yes yes yes but it was
done with more energy and longer pulses
and that would be dealt with less energy
and shorter pulses and I think should
probably CPA to get up to the 90 or
hundreds and whatever harmonics stuff
but yeah we're all you know the short
pulse people know each other and so uh
it's always fun when you're colleagues
are the ones that win and that your
field is
recognized so uh one thing that again
going back to Galileo he was fascinating
with time as you know he measured you
know pendulums and he tied his uh he
tied his pulse to because there were
clots back then so question often comes
up how do you know these pulses are add
I mean what clock do you use I had Bill
Phillips from n on uh last early this
year maybe late last year and we talked
about uh lates and trapping and
measurement of time and the standards
and technology used for that how do you
know these pulses are really at a second
or you know Fus how do you actually well
actually this is why Pier agustini won
his is that he came up this rabbit and
I'm not going to explain it um out of
seconds but I'll tell you the simpler
one because back in the F second time
and and these will be just fancier
versions of the same is that Optical
pulses are the shortest pulses that
could to be created so you can't just
use a regular detector which uses
electrons because they move slower they
have mass they simply move slower and so
we use some kind all of these things
there some type of autocorrelation which
means that you really are are taking one
short pulse to measure another short
pulse and the correlation is really just
if you take the one short pulse with the
other and you know what's the overlap
what's the overlap what's the overlap
with the overlap and that's how you do
it and so as long as you have a short
enough pulse then of course we have this
thing where space because speed of light
speed of light the you know you can just
delay with a delay arm and know exactly
how how much in moving this SP hey there
fellow explorers of the impossible it is
I your Fearless host Professor Brian key
how are you enjoying this riveting
conversation with yet another Nobel
Prize winner she's the 17th on our show
but who's counting now here's a little
secret you can help me help you by
subscribing liking and leaving a review
on either the audio podcast or on
YouTube these reviews and thumbs up and
interactions as they're called give us a
huge boost in different algorithms that
seem to dictate our lives and all things
that are related to creative content
like this podcast so by hitting the
Subscribe or follow button giving us a
thumbs up and leaving a fstar review
where you can you'll enable me to bring
more of these Incredible Minds to the
show so please do that do it now before
you forget now back to the episode so
fellow Canadian Katie Mack who is now at
Perimeter Institute she's the Hawking
chair there I had her on many years ago
and I asked her about what can we do to
increase the enrichment of women and I'm
father of any uh daughters and I'm quite
happy with that she didn't want to talk
about it she felt like it's uh she gets
it too much and you know what do you
want to do what is she going to do
propose you have a pink circuit board
for the girls to use and a blue one for
the speculations on you know kind of the
the role that um you know how how how
things have changed what they need to
change and what I call the Nobel tax
which is that you're often asked
probably to comment on that what are
your feelings on on the how status of
women has changed over your career and
where you see it go well it's changed
but I don't think that's the point I
think the point is is that physics
itself is not VI pice Society um highly
and so if you look at medicine all these
other issues that they will say this is
why women don't want to do physics would
have been true in medicine as well and
yet now more women go to Medicine than
men and so Society right parents still
sell children that are good on science
become doctors if they're good on the
Arts to become lawyers maybe now there's
some computer science because there's so
much money in that but and this is how
Society values things it's with money if
you get paid really well that Society is
saying we value this physics is not one
of those valid things so it's a rare
thing doesn't matter if you're a man or
a woman and so this is where I sort of
stand until society says this is
something to do I find it very strange
to say why don't women want to do it
well yeah they just don't want to do it
so overall lift all boats and we
fractioned women that get invol I've
noticed many more women just in my
20-year career here that have gotten
involved with it and excelled and
starting to worry is there a pendulum
effect and I have to worry about my male
students because you know it's 60% of
all college graduates are women it's
gone out to S at some point we have to
worry about it um and there's certain
Fields I mean we have a School of
Optometry is the only English School of
Optometry in candala and it's mostly
women and I never hear anybody say wow
what happened used to be mostly men and
now it's mostly women and when do we
start asking where are the men yeah and
that doesn't seem to be a concern and
yet the the lack of women seem to be a
big concern in physics so I think we
have to always be concerned about it and
I think the other real problem and the
problem in the 70s in my time is that
women were told we could do anything but
the men weren't told you also have to do
your share and this comes even back to
if you think about Maria go mayor when
she won her Nobel Prize the newspaper
here wrote San Diego housewife wins a
Nobel Prize and that's because everybody
had to say it's okay that she's doing
size because she's also doing all of
your women's jobs too well this is not
possible it's not possible for us to do
twice as much right right so we will
have around the world gender Equity when
we also let men look after the children
and the elderly it bothered me during Co
that it was like well all the women have
to lose their jobs because they're the
ones who have to look after the kids or
look after Elder and like why I don't
think women are more caring than men I
think that's just as offensive of saying
that you know women aren't as smart as
men right there there's none of this you
know if everything was equal and
everybody took their share then
everybody you know could have an equal
shot at it and so this idea that yes men
should even be allowed to work morning
you toight and that women will just look
after it is wrong everybody has to take
the share or you know or you hire
nannies and housekeepers and everything
else and so that's fine it's a different
way to go last year on Twitter I tweeted
out uh the same tweet I put the image I
got the image from the Union Tribune
which is the San Diego newspaper that
printed that headline and I put it uh on
my Twitter account and I said and I
shared a screenshot from JP when you're
colorate in chemistry Francis Arnold
who's a friend of mine I'm the Widow of
my postdoctoral adviser Andrew Ling and
Cal and it said uh JPL uh mom wins oh no
it said it said Caltech mom wins Nobel
Prize son is JPL flight tech and it was
the same thing it's like completely
defined by but then just two weeks ago
when I can't pronounce her name Carolina
the Hungarian woman who won for Mr RNA
she won she was like yes I'm a mother of
a swimmer so it you know the kind of
attitudinal and Fran took it all she was
like well they corrected and down but
you know you wonder yeah how much things
Chang and how much do we put you know
just men and women at a disadvantage by
kind of antagonizing this this you know
relationship which as you said should be
a mutual thing it shouldn't be abut and
now many of us you know unsung and not
just that you're taking care of kids
it's that at our age I'll taking care of
my parents exactly and we're kind of
sandwiched in and we have way too much
stuff going on that brings up something
you've done um some heroic uh videos
that will get probably more than this
one unfortunately views on YouTube with
a Wired Magazine I think it was and
millions of views explaining different
Las but I want to ask you more generally
um do scientists have an obligation to
communicate with lay people or should
you know should we have more you know
just socialization people in their LS or
in their you know cubicles and
chalkboard and so forth what do you view
as an obligation of a scientist to
communicate his or her research to the
public that pays their salary at some
level well not everybody's meant to be a
communicator and I but I would like
universities to start paying more
attention and that make sure that every
area of physics there's at least one
person that gets coaching and gets the
opportunity to go out and explain it I
think it's important um I've started um
like I'm co-director and but I was s of
the instigator for this new network on
trust and Science and um we start
scientists have to have conversations
with other people so that they
understand the scientific process I
don't know that people have to know each
area of Science and I don't think that's
really critical I think they have to
understand the scientific process why do
things take so long why you know so
masking was one of these things that
people started to get really frustrated
about and yet it was really a science
experiment happening in front of them
and scientists would oh okay they they
now tested this and found that so this
is why it has to change and to a
scientist that made sense but to other
people they kept they don't know what
they're doing they don't know what
they're doing and so this is where I
think we have to get out and start
really just explaining the process
explaining the time scales explaining
all of these things there are certain
areas of Science and in physics at the
Astro that you can ually get people out
for public talks but along with that who
my daughter's in astrophysics she's
already given a couple of public talks
as a graduate student so they also
because the public is willing to come
they also get the experience of learning
how to give public talks and most
science students do not get that
training so I think the university has
to start having better communication
teams working with the scientists um and
giving us also more opportunities to get
out there and but certainly permeter
Institute in watero transformed it I
mean it was hard to get a seat at their
Wednesday talks once a month right they
brought in fabulous speakers and they
just sold out right away so there is an
appetite for it and we have to tap into
it m absolutely okay well we've reached
the end of the scheduled uh questions
that I had except for these final four
existential questions you're free not to
answer them you're free to answer as
long or short as who Li me about my name
I know I want to ask you first about
your name yes indeed Donna Theo strip so
tell me about Theo is there any uh
relationship theology
theoy theodolite no my older sister was
named an after my mother's mother okay
and my father's mother's name was
Theodosia and so my mother said there's
no way I'm ging my daughter named theod
doia but so she said I'll put it in the
middle name and we're going to cut it to
Theo and that's where it comes from but
really I mean I used to not use the
middle name much most people don't use
the middle name right but now it's sort
of a different kind of name very few
women some men go by it from Theodore
and so but then so why don't I even use
it most people have the two initials on
their papers um but my very first paper
uh I was very interested in making sure
that they understood that I was a woman
you know because it was rare to be a
woman in the laser business and so uh
the paper was adop Communications and it
let you put your full so I just wrote
Don a stri and and I didn't you know so
that was long enough I didn't need the
Theo and then um so all of my uh papers
from my gr time it's just D Strickland
and then I go to work with Paul corham
and I see that he's PB corham and I well
if you're PB cor I should be DT
Strickland so I switched which of course
is wrong because now to find somebody
you have to pick and I didn't really
catch on to that and then it's funny I
go to Livermore and I work with this
brand new grad student Todd DM who's now
a well-known professor at Texas Austin
uh but he said no I don't want our first
paper go I don't want to publish with DT
Strickland I want to publish with d
Strickland that's what I want to publish
with and I let this gr student could me
all right let's go back so from that on
I've always just been DGL I think things
worked out so for the best so the first
thing I do is um hearken to the uh the
Nobel Prize itself so part of what
Alfred Nobel did as you know probably
better than anybody and me certainly was
that he wanted to do uh kind of imbue
the Nobel Prize with a social aim and
that was to improve man for the
betterment of all mankind so in in
Judaism we have this concept something
called an ethical will which is um not
monetary not what you're going to do
with your you know fraction of the Nobel
prize winning uh the gold medal but uh
what wisdom or knowledge that you most
want to transmit to your biological but
also your ideological SS of which
there's many I think that you know and
this has come up in this study where the
Stanford professor and some of the
professors looked at the fact that our
research productivity goes down I think
the one thing that once you win the
Nobel Prize I think uh because people
listen to us and they don't listen to
other scientists the onus is on us to
start talking about the importance of
science I think I'm a big believer that
it's an economic driver obviously can
help things with medicine and all these
other things I also think it's important
for for people to understand that you
can be working on something like
studying nuclear magnetic resonance not
realizing that it's going to end up
being a magnetic resonance imagy machine
in a hospital 50 years later right and
so you have to F let um scientists have
that time in that you know just area to
explore whatever they want to explore
because you don't know what's going to
lead down there so I think that's the
one thing I would say is that um we do
have to get out there and play our role
as a bors for science all you got the
next question uh so but this podcast
originated um as part of the Arthur C
Clark Center for human imagination which
I'm associate director of here at UCS
and um I'd like to uh address the next
three question final three questions uh
to different aspects of his career but
we'll tailor it to your take on it so
one have you seen the movie 2001 A Space
Odyssey no because I don't like science
fiction you don't like science fiction
okay well there is uh I'll then I'll
phrase it in the form of Richard fan
Richard fan was once asked what is the
um shortest sentence that contains the
densest amount of information of that
human beings have learned about the
universe and I usually say what kind of
thing would you put on a time capsule
that would last a billion years um what
do you think is the most impressive
aspect as as U Arthur Sark said any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic so what is
the most magical form of Technology
you're allowed to say see but I it's up
to you what is the most I was going to
say I thought it was an expression
because I think f equals ma is still the
most the strongest thing it's just such
a small equation and just has been used
for all these hundreds of years f equals
ma Newton uh Newton got that one right
and um you know can't be beat can't be
yeah fan had the what you call the
atomic hypothesis that everything is
made with these little atoms that have
continually whirling around electrons
around the nucleus so then the the next
question has to do with advice to a
young Gana and it goes like this the
name of this podcast is Into The
Impossible and the statement that Arthur
C Clark made was the only way to
determine the limits of the possible is
to go beyond them into the impossible so
I'm going to ask you what aspect of life
mystified you uh that if you got to
spend 30 no 30 seconds with a
20-year-old Donna Strickland what would
you tell her if I no I'm not that deep a
thinker I just keep going I just keep
walking down my path I don't think too
deeply about it is that because you
wouldn't trade the experiences that
you've had and anything you do to the
Past will necessarily modify you know
I've just been such an incredibly lucky
human being through my whole life you
know obviously I wouldn't really want to
change it other people could look at it
and go you know I was unbelievably shy
as a kid and that maybe held me back on
the other hand it directed where I
wanted to go because I at one point
decided that I would go to university
where I didn't know anybody to walk
myself out of that and that's what led
me to go to lasers so wasn't that lucky
um to follow my husband I took a job as
a member of technical staff at Princeton
and I thought I was giving up the
academic thing I chose that time to have
my two children where I was quite sick
through all the pregnancies couldn't
have done it as an academic so wasn't
that lucky that somehow I just said fine
I give up on my career I got to have my
two children and then I still got back
and had an academic career and two
children who would have thought that was
possible but it was and so I've just
walked through life without a clear
plant and life just kept working out FR
you as my grandmother it's say dance
Between The Raindrops well I think
herard said that you can um life must be
lived going forward but it only makes
sense when you look back okay the final
question with your delightful
forbearance has to do with things that
you maybe have you changed your mind
about and it goes like this again Arthur
Clark had all these quips one was for
every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert but his favorite thing
uh in this way to wrap up this
conversation is the following statement
he said when an elderly I'm not call you
elderly but an elderly and distinguished
scientist says something is possible he
or she is very likely to be correct but
when he or she says something is
impossible they are very likely to be
wrong and I want to ask you what have
you changeed your mind about what have
you been wrong about do you agree with
that St SED I don't know that I would
ever say anything's impossible uh my
husband kids me about how I I always you
know used to say I would never do this
that or everything and I've gone I I
told my husband I would never get
married but I did I would never have
children but I did so you know you I
never you know you don't know where
life's taking you so there's no point
putting limits on it but um I hope
nothing's impossible I still am waiting
for something to be better than quantum
mechanics I think we will get there
someday I just don't know if it's going
to be in my life time fantastic Donna
Strickland thank you so much for sharing
so much your time with us today visiting
us in s Diego and I hope you have many
happy returns here back to San Diego
Thank you thank you hey there it's me
your beloved host Professor Brian keting
are you enjoying my conversation with
this newest Nobel Prize winner to be
featured on the into the impossible
podcast Donna Strickland well what if I
told you there's more of the good stuff
that you can have access to and all you
have to do to get it is go to my mailing
list which you can join at briank
king.com by joining you also enter a
giveaway for a piece of 4 billion year
old space dust how cool is that and if
you have a edu email address you're
guaranteed to win so go to Brian
king.com and you can enter in the popup
splash screen that you'll see there and
I will see you in the next episode with
my utmost
thanks